the mascot swallowed her like this do
you guys remember during 9 11
[Music]
.
you guys know who Olivia picardo is yes
she was the inventor of the the ship
Rudder on the back that makes it turn
holy [__] it's awesome are you [__]
serious yeah Argentinian your wrist is
so strong right now Ryan I mean I get a
lot of people nobody knows who she is
look at him
she is a baseball player for for Brown
University there's a female baseball
team she is the first woman to play
division one baseball that is pretty
tight that's the League of Their Own is
she on a guy's team or she there's a
female [__] she's so good that she has
to be in the in the league call me
sexist but I thought women just played
softball you're sexist that's what I
thought and then I saw this article and
I was like well how's about that so this
so she didn't invent the rudder should
not invent the rudder no that was the
Germany we fact checked that
so um yeah she's playing division one
baseball right kind of a big deal and
she I don't want to show you guys how
inspirational this is dude I had no idea
there was baseball team girl baseball
teams are you gonna buy tickets now here
she is
let's see what the uniforms look like
this has never happened before this is
the first time she um
the first pitch at Fenway Park oh here
we go
wait so if she's a baseball player why
should you throw in the first pitch
because it's an honor how come she's not
real like really based what's going on
[Laughter]
she's not a real baseball player no she
is no you gotta be kidding me would you
say that why would you say she's not a
real baseball because she's a woman you
think cause her [__]
it looks like
like curveball it goes to the side she
did Pitch the curve that's called a ball
though yeah the dude the guy gave the
wrong well what's the point of pitching
a curve if it's just starting off a day
I don't think she meant to I don't think
she meant but but people are saying this
is super cool because she's showing
little girls everywhere that even adult
women can throw like them which I think
is really a beautiful who is this woman
the artist no she no this is 100 facts I
don't know which one's true and faking
Olivia the thing I said was true but the
boat the runner thing I thought that was
Jermaine Dupree yeah damn it Ryan
baseball player for Brown University
first one to play division one so she's
a straight up baseball player so yeah
maybe she's not a pitcher that's why the
pitch wasn't that good yeah what is a
position is he a batter or like it
actually doesn't say if she's a quick
mess yeah maybe she's a quick math
I'm assuming she's a pitcher I mean yeah
it's kind of like making fun of Shaq for
not being able to do free throws right
yeah thank you that's fair it's a skill
set in this Shaq throws curveballs too
yeah and his hands are just too big
because if she was the pitcher for the
V1 team I'll be like Outfield I don't
feel so she's a [__] catcher well she
said she made four starts in the
Outfield and one on the mound so she
actually did Pitch she pitched once okay
because is that what that means if
you're on the mound yeah cool all the
mound is but she's like back up to the
backup pitcher maybe she was a little
nervous who cares her baseball card's
still gonna be worth a good amount oh
that's true I love Steve making a whole
[__] video about this because she
couldn't pitch right no no this is a new
story this is just we're just covering
the news news this is a big I feel like
there has been other women starting the
game with the pitch and it looks decent
she's a pro player and she can't even do
that and these girls are like singers
and celebrities that [__] throw out
the first pitch and it looks decent I
saw this one girl do a backflip and then
throw the oh she's great that's sick
that girl's dope she did a [__] oh my
God
and it bounced on the plate right it
bounced just in front of the plate right
it went past it didn't even make it past
the mound apparently yeah it didn't make
it possible the amount is what she
stands on it rolled there I'm surprised
that I'm just shocked still that there's
actually a a female baseball team I
thought they'd do t-balls well no she
she's she's the first woman to play in a
division one base so they don't do
t-balls with men okay okay that's kind
of tight
so she identified as a man
in a man in just a I mean she's in the
regular League oh yeah it's a co-ed
League it is now because it's so good
that they have to go hey I mean you're
Anthony do you have some thoughts or no
I'm just uh gathering information so I
can make it
why are you laughing so much yeah why
are you laughing so hard
her accomplishments
that's what it seems like
it's a slapstick comedy she's changing
this definition of like you throw like a
girl because she's like all my life I've
been told I've been done like a girl so
now I don't [__] do that anymore and
I'm an inspiration to all women look
right I think she got a great arm
because it looked like the ball had some
heat on it but it just was Loft Center
hey to be fair it got there but it was
just it was just like way over there
yeah it was like over over there because
if you ask me to throw a first pitch
there's a good shot oh it's gonna it's
gonna hang right yeah it's gonna be all
right are you guys good with balls Ball
Sports because I feel like you're either
good with the ball sport I'm better at
balls coming at me
yeah you're a good ball catcher yeah
you're a catcher I'm more of a ball
handler like I can handle the ball
really well if I'm being surprised by
balls then I'm probably pretty good at
it because like it like but if I'm
preparing for it mentally right too much
pressure a lot of pressure dude that
first pitch people [__] up the first
pitch const that's a lot of pressure it
is a lot of pressure at least a few more
especially if you're trying to like put
some weight into it you know if you're
actually trying to throw it versus just
get it to the Target honestly I thought
exactly she I think she got in her own
head a little bit
it says she didn't
[Laughter]
you're stupid
it says she didn't
this is the first case of a girl joining
guy Sports and then crushing it uh yeah
but I don't I mean you know there's some
controversy about if she's crushing it
or not
it's all over my laptop
I'm not about is she crushing it and all
the different forms I go to anonymously
and I comment about how she's not
crushing it something maybe so you know
how like when um there was like a there
was like a thing I read recently where
um like
this girl was like all men lie oh Ben
lie and then the dude was like have you
ever seen the comment section of like an
obese like woman
photo yeah because all the girls are
going work like beautiful like in this
case are they going like oh that pitch
was right on like are all of her like
home girls going like oh that was
amazing they're blaming the catcher for
not moving like for not diving to the
left yo honestly there's no way dude if
I'm her homegirl I'm probably also like
you [__] up like that's funny that
that's okay to be funny about it that
was one of the careful boys we would all
be making clown around each other making
fun of each other I think if she's in
like like division one you said yeah
then that is like she got some thick
skin you should be able to like make fun
of that that's pretty yeah for sure
that's the shack example is a really
good one right like there's no way the
entire [__] League was not making fun
of Shaq even though he's like one of the
greatest players of all time but you get
to make yeah
it's like now she's inducted it to be
accepted as one of them and they she got
to play the whole game everyone does
with being roasted she could be the
sickest you know female baseball player
but you could still be like yo that was
a terrible pitch I think uh the letter
do it again
[Music]
no
which is history it says no she was a
band from the park I figured
the mascot swallowed her like this do
you guys remember during 9 11 uh when
George W threw out the first pitch at at
New York at the Yankee Stadium oh yeah
and like they made a big deal out of it
like they like [__] made this like
video about what a [__] hero moment
it was for George W to stand up after
the towers got hit and he's giving hope
to everybody if he can just get the
[__] ball across home played United
We Stand brother yeah and he and he was
very braveable it's like he's wearing a
bulletproof ballistics vest and then he
got it all the way across home plate and
threw a strike and it and everyone came
together again
it just makes me
yeah people that is such an American
thing of like the first pitch is
everything yeah it's a cool tradition
yeah but no one watches baseball that
much no more dude they're hurting right
yeah viewership viewership sponsorships
everything's down yeah we gotta stop
watching baseball so much I think there
should be less games you know what it is
I think there's just they're not as
competitive you just can't watch on TV
as much I think it's too it's just so
slow if you're gonna go go to the game
no but even every baseball game I've
gone to I [__] fell asleep the
saddest thing is that like baseball's
down but like movies about baseball is
up like Moneyball is a freaking amazing
movie great movie I'll watch that all
day but not an actual game yeah because
Brad Pitt's eating the whole time every
scene he's munching the pace is a little
different I think Sandlot is what really
got me into baseball though oh yeah dude
it wasn't Angels in the Outfield oh that
dude like that whole era but also the
thing about The Sandlot baseball was the
subplot it's more about the kids boys
being friends and like was it the was it
the rookie with Dennis Quaid nobody saw
the roof you guys remember rookie of the
year was that is that what I'm talking
about kid breaks his arm and again
throws a 200 miles turns into a cannon
that that was such a freaking amazingly
written movie What About Angels in the
Outfield Colleen's favorite movie
to this day you can go up to Georgetown
Gordon-Levitt and go like this and he's
like oh man [__] you
come on Field of Dreams feel the dreams
yeah
James Earl Jones is great in that movie
too yeah yeah these are all great movies
you mean Terrence man A League of Their
Own hey I rewatched that recently it's
really good I think it's hilarious it's
really good and Madonna kills it I
haven't seen it in years but I remember
I don't see kids playing baseball
anymore like just like Street bar in a
cold cold Sack or like I don't see them
doing that [__] they shouldn't because
they'll get beat up I don't really live
anywhere where there's a baseball field
to see kids playing baseball I see them
at the field like at the park but when
we were kids we would just pull up on
the street or the cul-de-sac or whatever
I see a lot of soccer I play a lot of
stickballs football football is live I
mean do you see a lot of kids play
outside these days in general in general
I do when I'm in the bushes I would put
my binoculars
hahaha
[Music]